let me start by updating you on the
latest information from the government's
Cobra data file and can I turn to the
first slide please the slide show data
on the use of different types of
transport and this graph showed these
graphs shows significant Falls in the
use of public transport rail buses the
tube in London and even before the
lockdown was introduced on the 23rd of
March this is welcome
it shows the public's responded
positively to our request to avoid
public transport wherever possible the
use of Motor Vehicles fell substantially
initially and has since risen steadily
they're not back to the level seen mid
March again this is what we would expect
as we have introduced some easements to
the lockdown and encourage people to
return to work one form of transport
which has seen a significant increase is
cycling it's great to see so many people
switching to clean green mode of
transport with significant public health
benefits and it's very encouraging to
see next slide please
the number of tests carried out or
posted out in the UK has risen past the
five million mark for the first time
that's five million five thousand five
hundred and sixty-five
this includes a record two hundred and
twenty thousand and fifty seven tests
carried out or posted outs yesterday a
new total the new high total two hundred
and eighty 1661 people have tested
positive that's an increase of one
thousand eight hundred and five cases
since yesterday the graph shows a steady
steadily falling number of identified
cases on a seven-day rolling average
despite that increase in testing third
slide please this slide shows the latest
data from hospitals five hundred and
five people were admitted to hospital
with current virus in England on 2nd of
June marginally from the 475 a week ago
but down from the peak of 3121 on the
second of April 604 coronavirus patients
are in mechanical
halation beds in the UK down from 783 a
week ago and down from a peak of 3301 on
the 12th of April 4th slide please
this slide shows what's happening in
hospitals across the country there are
now seven thousand three hundred and
twelve people in hospital with corona
virus in the UK down 15% from 8558 a
week ago and down from a peak of 20,000
699 on the 12th of April as the graph
shows while there is some variation most
nations and regions in the UK are
broadly following a similar pattern and
last slide please
this slide shows the daily figures for
those who have sadly lost their lives
after testing positive for coronavirus
across all settings the total number of
deaths now stands at 39 thousand nine
hundred and four that's an increase of
176 fatalities since yesterday and
that's the lowest working week day level
of fatalities were measured by a
seven-day rolling average the daily
number of deaths currently stands at 241
down from a peak of 943 on the 14th of
April these figures are a reminder that
over 19 still represents a very real
threat that the fight still goes on to
defeat it and that there are tragically
still too many people across the country
who are losing loved ones our thoughts
are with the ball as we made clear in
recent weeks our roads recovery must be
carefully and cautiously managed most
importantly we must avoid a second
inspect in infection spike this careful
deliberate approach has been central to
the restart of public transport in
advance of previous easing of the
lockdown we've ensured transport
availability was increased to allow for
adequate
social distancing in addition we've also
announced measures to help people choose
other forms of transport for example
with a record to billion pounds invested
in cycling and walking as well as the
acceleration of a scooter trials brought
forward to the end of this month
meticulous planning alongside the
considerable effort of passengers
avoiding public transport has worked
well so far there's been an absence of
crowding even as passenger numbers have
picked up partly thanks to the work that
Sir Peter handy has been doing but these
challenges are about to increase we
expect conditions permitting that the
next easing of the restrictions will
occur on Monday the 15th of June
non-essential shops will reopen and some
children will return to secondary school
that means there'll be more pressure on
our public transport to help meet that
demand we're ramping up services on
buses trams and trains with substantial
government funding but we still need to
do more so today I want to highlight the
measures that will help take to keep us
safe and reduce the risk of coronavirus
particularly on public transport there
are three points I'd like to highlight
first let me reiterate and this is
really important if you can work from
home you should continue to do so if you
cannot work from home you should avoid
transport wherever possible and if you
must use public transport you should
follow guidance including avoiding the
rush-hour itself second I can announce
that as of Monday the 15th of June face
coverings will become mandatory on
public transport
that doesn't mean surgical masks which
we must keep for clinical settings
it means the kind of face covering you
can easily make at home but be
exemptions to these rules for very young
children the disabled people
and those were breathing difficulties
but broadly as we come through this
phase we're doing what many other
countries have asked transport users to
do and as passenger numbers increase and
we expect this trend to continue we need
to ensure every precaution is taken on
buses trains aircraft and on ferries
with more people using transport the
evidence suggests the wearing face
coverings offers some albeit limited
protection against the spread of the
virus a face covering helps protect our
fellow passengers it's something that we
can each do to help each other and
whilst it also remains true the measures
like maintaining social distancing
washing your hands remain the most
critical things to do we also know on
public transport keeping two metres
apart is not always possible at all
times
indeed the guidance explicitly
recognizes this fact so when more people
return to the network from the 15th of
June onwards we will they will be
required to wear face coverings on
transport network will make these rule
changes under the national rail
conditions of travel and the public
service vehicle regulations for buses
this will mean that you can be refused
travel if you don't comply and you could
be fined alongside transport operators
this will be enforced by the British
Transport Police if necessary but I
expect the vast majority of people where
need to be forced into this because
wearing a face covering helps protect
others and most people simply want to
help defeat this disease
of course frontline staff those in
contact with passengers doing such an
important job at this crucial time will
also need to wear face coverings in the
coming days the government will work
with the unions who've been supportive
for which I'm very grateful transport
operators and the police to ensure that
they have the supplies they need to be
safe and provide reassurance to the
public these measures apply in England
but we're working with the devolved
administration's ahead of implementation
third - ease pressure on public
transport I want to update you on the
measures we're taking to boost
alternative ways to travel now the
vehicle showrooms opening again there's
a growing range of electric cars mopeds
motorbikes on sale and as our economy
gets moving their popularity will it
continue to increase later this month
we'll be introducing the fix your bike
voucher worth fifty quid
we'll have hundreds of thousands of more
Road worthy bikes on the road as a
result of this program and then there's
the cycle to work scheme which enables
employees to buy a tax-free bike an
effective saving at twenty five to
thirty nine percent and that scheme has
been extended to cover ebikes as well
meaning the cyclists can cover longer
distances by getting assistance on those
uphill stretches and this is a great
time to start using them as we redesign
our landscape to cope with millions more
cyclists and pedestrians in the months
ahead the evidences the commuters are
already responding despite fewer people
traveling over the past few weeks during
this crisis we've actually seen around
100 percent increase in weekday cycling
and at weekends that increase has been
up to 200% compared to the pre kovat 19
levels we want to use this recovery to
permanently change the way we travel
with huge levels of investment who are
bringing forward green transport
improvements that otherwise would have
taken years or decades to achieve and in
the short term whilst there's still a
threat for the virus they'll help keep
millions of people avoiding public
transport journeys and in the longer
term
they'll help transform our country into
a lower carbon cleaner and greener place
to live our history shows us how quickly
we can adapt as a nation just as we did
200 years ago when Britain invented the
railway and just as we did in the 20th
century when we embrace the motorcar and
then in the 1950s when we launched the
first passenger jet L
coincidentally designed and built in my
Hatfield constituency each of these
transport revolutions was triggered by a
unique alignment of people and events
brilliant engineers and entrepreneurs
cutting-edge new technologies supported
governments and the needs of citizens
combining to bring about change and now
we need them now we stand on the verge
of a new transport revolution this time
not limited to one particular means of
travel but rather to all forms of
transport a green transport revolution
which will help us rebuild a stronger
more prosperous Britain as well as a
cleaner and healthier one too